bonsoir des garçons pourquoi vous êtes
conseiller municipal d'opposition divers
gauche président du groupe saint cyr
l'école avant son ensemble vous avez
décidé de vous mobiliser contre les
nuisances sonores de l'aérodrome de
saint cyr après la contestation autour
de la gare de la verrière à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines m'a parlé de
la contestation autour de cet aérodrome
à présent temps de 7,8 vous étiez déjà
venu par le passé notamment avec et
pardon eu l'occasion d'en parler sur ce
plateau vous n'étiez pas venu au monde a
parlé de cette contestation
qu'est ce qui n'a pas changé depuis la
situation est toujours la même il n'y a
pas eu d'amélioration précédent
reportage
si vous me permettez je vais faire un
petit retour en arrière sur la
présentation l'aérodrome de saint cyr
c'est un patrimoine historique pour
l'aviation civile
et c'est aussi un patrimoine historique
pour la ville il a sévi dans le berceau
de l'aviation voilà il a fêté son
centenaire l'année passée et donc c'est
quelque chose auquel les saint cyriens
sont attachés et on aura sûrement
l'occasion d'en reparler tout à l'heure
pour ma part moi je suis pas centenaire
vous mais j'ai une caractéristique par
rapport à beaucoup de mes collègues
conseillers municipaux c'est que je suis
né à saint cyr l'école donc cette vie je
la connais cet aérodrome je le connais
depuis que je suis petit j'ai fait mon
baptême de l'air gilles fait les fêtes
de la ville et donc j'y suis attaché et
donc la démarche que j'ai entrepris
aujourd'hui elle n'est pas tellement
contre l'aérodrome
mais contre les nuisances que subissent
au jour le jour les riverains ça c'est
pour la forme parce que forcément ça
drôle région il ya des hélicoptères
forcément des nuisances il faut les
limiter en tout cas c'est ce que vous
dites pas les supprimer mais limitée
alors si on reprend un petit peu
l'historique de la démarche en tant que
conseiller municipal ch était déjà
intervenu lors de conseils pour demander
à monsieur le maire de prendre un
certain nombre de dispositions destinées
à apporter la quiétude aux alentours de
l'aérodrome
j'ai trouvé que ça n'allait pas assez
vite j'ai trouvé qu'ils avaient pas
assez d'action j'ai trouvé que les
choses ne bougeaient pas et notamment le
bruit des hélicoptères et devenait de
plus en plus proéminent devenait de plus
en plus gênant donc en 2000 ans j'ai
commencé à écrire en préfecture et
notamment pour demander au préfet qu'ils
mettent en oeuvre
l'application directe de la
réglementation qui interdisait le survol
de des zones de forte densité qui
interdisait les stationnaire les
choletais n'a pas été respectée pour
savoir si l'addition la dernière réponse
du préfet m'informe que un certain
nombre de pilotes sont aujourd'hui
poursuivis pour infraction
l'activité d'école a arrêté son activité
et les pilotes sont poursuivis pour
avoir enfreint les règlements que
visiblement tout le monde connaissait
donc ça c'était 2011
et puis là-bas les beaux jours
reviennent et j'ai pris un petit peu les
devants sous le soleil
sûrement à la faveur d'une éclaircie et
j'ai écrit une lettre aux riverains
parce que bon je suis conseiller
municipal mais je suis pas chevalier
blanc allait défendre quelque chose
quand vous avez pas les principaux
intéressés qui vous suivent qui vous
rejoignent et qui conforte votre analyse
c'est pas mon ce pas mon genre d'objet
j'ai fait une démarche j'ai vu que
j'avais informé de l'ensemble de mes
actions
là je suis revenu devant les plus
proches riverains et je leur ai demandé
qu'il me fasse un retour sur cette nuit
question comment il avait quels sont les
retours au jeu seulement par rapport à
ces différentes questions vous avez posé
sur ce sentiment autour des nuisances
les retours aujourd'hui sont claires
déjà le premier c'est que la quasi
totalité des réponses ne veulent pas la
fermeture de l'aérodrome c'est clair
c'est net c'est précis donc j'ai déjà
assisté à des réunions publiques où
bernard de bain disait qu'il envisageait
le berre actuelle disait qu'il
envisageait de fermer l'aérodrome ce que
les choses soient claires je suis pas du
tout sur cette ligne
les riverains non plus par contre les
riverains
sont à bout excédée parce que la
problématique des hélicoptères subsiste
un hélicoptère ça fait du stationnaire
pendant un quart d'heure pendant 20
minutes
et puis un que un moment il est sur la
partie haute de l'aérodrome
il gêne une partie de saint cyr un
moment il est sur la partie basse
ils gênent le reste de saint cyr enfants
justement voit les entendant un instant
ça nous allait réaliser un micro
trottoir juste auparavant une petite
précision vous êtes conseil municipal
vous l'avez encore redit oui mais
conseiller municipal dans l'opposition
divers gauche c'est à dire que vous êtes
en train d'élaborer aussi un programme
par rapport aux municipales en ce moment
ça va en voir un petit peu quelles sont
les propositions les attentes à l'arrêt
des habitants de sens hier clairement on
n'a pas attendu ces dernières semaines
pour aller voir les habitants de saint
cyr quand on a eu un certain nombre de
choses qui ne nous convenait pas sur le
quartier de l'epidaure la destruction
d'une école la condamne la construction
à l'aide d'un partenariat public privé
on a agi on a informé les gens quand sur
le quartier j'y mets pas en cause votre
implication tout au long du mandat mais
juste là sur cette action je vends mon
précise que vous pensez ou non à cette
campagne des municipales
est-ce qu'il ya ça aussi dans un coin de
votre tête est ce que ça va permettre
d'élaborer un programme est ce que
clairement vous serez candidat par
exemple je vais je vais plagié un ancien
président ça m'arrive d'y penser en me
rasant d'accord là
je suis président du groupe des élus de
gauche
je suis pas membre d'un parti c'est
peut-être pas innocent parce que la
gauche souvent ça résonne hong kong en
composantes multiples et ils m'ont
choisi moi pour assumer la présidence du
groupe donc effectivement je travaille
depuis un certain temps depuis un an et
demi je fais ce qu'on appelle peut-être
à tort les ateliers d'avant son ensemble
et ont réuni un groupe d'une trentaine
de personnes sur des thématiques
municipal
si vous êtes candidat vous serez
candidat avec l'investiture du parti
socialiste je vous pourrez la voir et je
pense que je serai candidat avec
l'investiture des partis qui composent
la gauche saint cyrienne sinon est ce
que je serai candidat tout seul sur mon
propre nom ça n'a pas de sens voilà
pourquoi c'est pour ces quelques
précisions au tour des municipales on va
se concentrer sur ce dossier de
l'aérodrome témoin aussi comment les
choses avancent mais c'est tout de même
important de préciser qu'il ya des
échéances municipales tout le monde le
sait et forcément ça reste dans un coin
de la tête quand on aborde les dossiers
qui posent problème comme à la verrière
d'ailleurs tout à l'heure là on va
écouter les riverains voir un petit peu
s'ils sentent justement ceux ci l'ont ce
sentiment de de nuisances sonores autour
de l'aérodrome
non puisqu'on entend pas du tout ici
dans ce coin de censure c'est peut-être
les habitants qui sont situés juste à
côté il y aura peut-être la zac de la
nouvelle zac est en cours de
construction qui va être très gêné c'est
vrai que des personnes se plaignent mais
je connais aussi des gens qui profitent
bien des avions et je trouverais ça
dommage que l'aérodrome disparaissent
ensuite j'ai entendu l'avion mais ces
trois jeunes poissons
on attend aussi de torhout alors
les nuisances sonores elles sont pas
plus importantes que celles des
hélicoptères qui viennent sur la
circulation
la surveillance un peu des routes quand
je suis arrivé sur saint cyr maloud
hommes étaient déjà là donc la nuisance
existait et je l'aï acceptée comme telle
ça c'est dit au niveau des hélicoptères
ça considérablement amplifiée ces
dernières années ce sont les
hélicoptères qui poserait plus de
problème
oui je crois que y'a peut-être pas eu
unanimité mais vous voyez que la
majorité des gens disent quand on est
venu s'installer à saint cyr
éventuellement à proximité aux normes
étaient là on connaissait les nuisances
alors ça veut pas dire que parce que le
trafic il a quand même beaucoup augmenté
donc il ya eu des chartes de bonne
intelligence avec l'installation de
silencieux c'est des choses qu'il faut
continuer parce qu'il ya dialoguer avec
les utilisateurs de l'aérodrome
il faut le continuer mais saint cyr
c'est un poumon vert cet aérodrome ce
que je regretterai mois à la limite
c'est que les saint cyriens ont perdu
l'habitude de l'utiliser
beaucoup pensent que c'est une propriété
privée alors on peut pas s'approcher des
avions parce qu'il ya la législation de
l'aviation civile mais on peut
facilement aller voir les décollages et
je pense que si plus de saint cyrien se
déplacer et aller voir cet aérodrome
peut-être qu'il serait plus plus enclins
à le défendre
il n'y a pas d'inquiétudes autour de la
sécurité aussi parce qu'il vient en
accédant récemment dans le départ depuis
les émeutes justement un petit avion de
ce type qui sait qui s'est écrasé oui
c'est un avion d'après les informations
que j'ai qui avait décollé de saint cyr
l'école
bien sûr bien sûr c'est une grande
tristesse c'est des gens qui sont
décédés la part par l'amour du métier
qui voulait enseigner et lin chi qui
apprenait ce métier de pilote c'est un
sport mécanique c'est dangereux dire qu'
il n'y a aucun problème de sécurité ce
serait nier par ces incidents aussi
dramatiques soit il qui est isolé il
vise à mon manque de sécurité comme ça
il me semble que les pilotes sont des
gens sont des professionnels ou au moins
des amateurs très très confirmé qu' on
décolle pas comme ça il ya toujours des
points chauds qui sont faits au
démarrage et voilà squat on compte le
nombre d'accidents on n'en recense que
un ou deux sur les quatre aérodrome que
compte la région parisienne on l'a dit
vous êtes venus ce soir nous parler de
ces nuisances et ce courrier sonore que
vous avez adressé donc aux riverains
avec les différentes réponses et qui se
focalise un petit peu autour du cas des
hélicoptères vous nous avez répondu sur
cette question dans le micro trottoir
tout à l'heure on a aussi entendu parler
du cas de la zac renard le futur
quartier qui sera très proche
là aussi vous serez j'imagine vigilants
un quartier qui devra être aménagée de
nouvelles habitations ça va durer sur
plus de dix ans l'aménagement de cette
ville dans la ville presque la zac
renard si on la lit à l'aérodrome
elle est forcément construite en dehors
de la zone de bruit puisque c'est la
législation personne ne construit en
dehors de la législation
donc les parties les plus exposées au
bruit seront les parties d'activité
industrielle il n'empêche que si le
décollage des hélicoptères continuent au
rythme où il est aujourd'hui
les riverains proches de la zac rona
sera forcément avec les mêmes troubles
que les autres riverains actuels vous
avez adressé le courrier aux riverains
nous a fait part de quelques retours que
vous avez eu quelle sera la suite de
l'action à présent alors la suite
on a deux appuis qui nous sont assez
proches on a le député jean philippe
mallet et une conseillère régionale
sandrine grand grande qui siège à la
commission consultative de
l'environnement de l'aérodrome réunis
par le préfet cette commission devrait
parce que traditionnellement elle se
réunit en juillet donc moi je collecte
encore un petit peu de réponses je vais
faire une synthèse je vais approcher le
député et la préfecture et je vais
demander à ces gens de de faire le
maximum est de prendre les choses en
main pour choeur on trouve une solution
mon but moi c'est pas la disparition des
hélicoptères mais on peut pas on peut
pas laisser une activité qui génère
autant de autant nuisances peut-être que
les hélicoptères doivent s'éloigner
encore un petit peu plus de la proche
banlieue parisienne et on sera bien sur
les évolutions de ce dossier merci
daniel garçons conseiller municipal à
saint cyr l'école d'être venu sur ce
plateau pour évoquer ces nuisances
aériennes à saint cyr ont poursuivi 7,8
et on passe à la chronique de
l'innovation ce soir